Salut ! Hier dans les commentaires, vous avez été nombreux à m'expliquer
que vous étiez à la bourre dans vos révisions.
J'ai dit OK, je vous écoute
et ce Master Class est dédié aux révisions à la bourre !
(Clin d'oeil à Jean De LaFontaine)
La cigale ayant chanté toute l'année se retrouva fort dépourvue
quand l'heure des exams fut venu.
Ou pas, d'ailleurs, peut être que vous avez bossé à fond mais ça vous stresse quand même.
Alors voici 7 règles qui vont vous permettre de vous optimiser sur un court temps pour réviser.
Que vous ayez déjà bien préparé le terrain, ou pas du tout.
On va tout de suite se débarrasser de la base, en se débarrassant justement de la junk food (mal bouffe)
Fini les chips, les conneries à grignoter.
Mangez des fruits, des légumes, du pain, du chocolat noir, c'est excellent, des vitamines.
Bref, essayez de privilégier une alimentation saine, et également des protéines.
Histoire de bien soigner votre corps aussi, vous devez bien dormir.
Et bien dormir, c'est 8 h de sommeil.
Et maintenant, j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous :
il vous reste tellement de temps pour réviser que vous allez cartonner !
Si je considère que vous dormez 8 h
et que vous avez besoin de 3 heures pour manger dans la journée,
ce qui est déjà pas mal, et que vous avez besoin d'1h50 pour les choses basiques
comme passer un coup de fil
se laver ....
il ne faut pas négliger son hygiène
bref, 1h50 pour faire des choses standard
et 10 min pour l'essentiel de votre journée
ça se passe en général à 17h en semaine
et à 11 h le week-end
malgré tout ça, les 3 h de repas,
les 2h pour faire autre chose
les 8 h de sommeil, il vous reste 10h !
C'est énorme, 10 h !
C'est énorme, ça !
On peut faire beaucoup de choses en 10 h.
Et si par exemple, il vous restait plus que 10 jours avant votre exam, ça vous fait quand même 100 h pour réviser.
Que faire durant toutes ces heures que vous avez à disposition ?
Il faut en premier éteindre l'ordi,
couper le téléphone mais vraiment le mettre en mode avion
ou le couper complètement, qu'il n'y ait aucune notification
se débarrasser de toutes ces tentations.
Et je sais de quoi je parle, je suis addict à mort.
Mais quand je travaille sur quelque chose de concret, je coupe tout complètement.
Oui, presque tout !
Donc faîtes une vraie bulle numérique.
Ensuite, au lieu d'essayer d'apprendre vos cours, relisez un maximum.
Dès que vous avez du temps, relisez
relisez, relisez, relisez, ça va être plus important, plus essentiel
que d'essayer d'apprendre concrètement le contenu. Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est trop tard pour ça !
Donc il va falloir vous imprégner un maximum de la globalité des choses.
Si vous avez fait des fiches, relisez les fiches tout le temps. Relisez-les, relisez-les, relisez-les
et si possible à voix haute. Même si vous avez plutôt une mémoire visuelle,
la mémoire auditive est quand même active et donc tout ce que vous pourrez récupérer est intéressant.
Si vous avez suivi ma vidéo sur le MindMap et que vous en avez fait, déjà bravo !
Et laissez tomber les fiches pour réviser plutôt les MindMap.
Et si vous n'avez rien fait, ni fiche, ni MindMap, ni quoi que ce soit,
c'est pas grave, là vous vous reconnectez et vous allez chercher les fiches sur le net.
J'ai vérifié aujourd'hui, il existe à peu près tout sur tout
pour tous les cursus et à tous les niveaux.
Ça, c'est vraiment la chance en 2016 de pouvoir accéder à tout ça,
cherchez des fiches qui sont déjà faîtes et téléchargez-les.
Sur ce court laps de temps, soyez stratégique, soyez malin et tapez dans les gros coeff.
Tapez dans les coef 9, tapez dans les coef 12 pour ceux qu'en ont, tapez dans les plus gros coef pour optimiser votre note globale.
A quelques jours des exams, c'est vraiment la bonne stratégie,
même si c'est une matière où vous êtes pas bon.
Vous allez limiter le nombre de points à rattraper.
Ensuite dès que possible, testez vous et testez vous le plus souvent possible.
Pour ça c'est pareil faîtes confiance au net,
y a des tests qui existent, y a des annales,
y a des annales aussi sur l'examen que vous allez passer.
Ça va vous préparer psychologiquement et ça va vous permettre aussi de mettre le doigt
sur ce que vous maîtrisez pas du tout pour pouvoir combler ces carences là.
En fait faut voir ça en 2 temps d'ailleurs : dès que vous avez un moment de libre
même à droite à gauche, relisez les fiches tout le temps.
Et sinon, dès que possible vous vous testez sur des questionnaires, sur des annales.
Vous identifiez ce qui vous fait galérer et vous relisez les fiches correspondantes.
Et pour terminer, je reviens encore sur le MindMap, sur la carte mentale,
essayez d'en faire comme même, en gribouillant.
Ça va vous permettre de structurer votre idée, d'avoir un vrai repère visuel.
Le fait de le créer, ça va s'ancrer encore plus en vous.
Le fait de le voir, ça va refaire marcher le visuel.
Le fait de le synthétiser, ça refait marcher la compréhension.
Et si vous le faîtes en parlant, ça fait encore marcher la mémoire auditive.
Voilà, c'était les meilleurs conseils que je pouvais vous donner pour les dernières révisions de l'ultime minute.
J'espère que vous allez cartonner à votre examen, quel qu'il soit, que ce soit un examen scolaire.
Peut-être que vous regarderez cette vidéo un jour avant de passer le permis,
peut-être pour un examen d'embauche.
Cartonnez tout, vous êtes les meilleurs.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, n'oubliez pas de me laisser un petit pouce en l'air.
Avis aux abonnés : mardi je ferai une vidéo avec vous sur skype
avec l'un d'entre vous via un tirage au sort.
Regardez sur twitter et sur facebook, vous avez les liens dans le descriptif.
Et si vous n'êtes pas abonné, il n'est jamais trop tard pour bien faire.
Je vous laisse cliquer là-haut, puisque le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
donc rendez vous demain à 11h.
Ciao !